نحن في جبهه وفي احدى النقاط والخنادق
الموجوده في هذه الجبهه نحن الان ندخل الى
هذا الخندق والذي يقود بشكل مباشر الى
اقرب نقطه مراقبه للقوات الروسيه هنا في
مراقبه القوات الاوكرانيه والذي يمتد على
مسافه امتار وكذلك محفور تحت الارض لامتار
من اجل ضمان سلامه تحرك القوات الروسيه
ويشكل نقطه مهمه للقوات الروسيه في مراقبه
القوات الاوكرانيه
نحن نصل الان الى اخر نقطه في الخندق وهي
نقطه التماس المباشر على هذا الاتجاه حيث
تتواجد القوات الاوكرانيه المسافه الفاصله
ما بين هذا الخندق او هذا نقطه المراقبه
هذه بحواليه الى 300 متر تتواجد قوات
الاوكرانيه تعتبر نقطه تماس مباشره ما بين
هذه القوات القوات الروسيه تقول بانها
تطبقه وتحكم السيطره على هذا المكان وتحكم
سيطرته على تواجد القوات الاوكرانيه هذه
النقطه هي نقطه مهمه بالاضافه الى نقط
تشتغل عليها القوات الروسيه لغه الالتفاف
من الشمال والشمال الغربي من اجل اطباق
اطباق الطوق على كل منافذ الدعم التي
تتوصل بها
كمرحله اخيره لاجل السيطره على هذه
المدينه التي لا تزال لحد الساعه تحت
السيطره الاوكرانيه وتخضع للسلطات
الاوكرانيه
الجزيره